you want to talk about an anticipated
movie of the year I'm pretty sure Cloud
Atlas is one of them so you know what
let's talk about it
finally Cloud Atlas
so Cloud Atlas isn't the story of
something it's many stories spanning
many centuries Cloud Atlas is written
and directed by the Wachowski which
you'll remember them from the matrix and
a few other things they more or less
been producing now but they were like
alright let's get in touch with the guy
who did Run Lola Run and we'll write and
direct a movie with him that's like
three hours long
luckily the point of Cloud Atlas isn't
the individual story so I don't have to
explain the stories to you the point of
Cloud Atlas is showing how everything is
intertwined and everything is connected
but it's spanning centuries it's big on
the whole reincarnation concept so
something you do in one life back here
will affect your later life hundreds of
years from now that's pretty much the
point of Cloud Atlas and it stars a lot
of people Tom Hanks is pretty much the
main star of this movie Tom Hanks and
Halle Berry Hugo Weaving the kid from 21
I don't know his name to me he's the kid
from 21 and in a movie with such big
scope there is a huge contrast
in-between people who've seen it people
either consider it the modern art
masterpiece of our time or they consider
it a piece of [ __ ] cloud Atlas is like
the Resident Evil 6 of movies funny
enough they've both come out at around
the same time some people love it some
people hate it you get a few different
stories that intertwine but in Cloud
Atlas it just spans you know centuries
and that's a bold move and that is cool
but you can't base the movie just for
the fact that it's bold there are people
who are like yeah well you know I you
know I'm not quite sure what I think
about it it's bold and I don't know if
you think that I'll make it easy for you
you hate the movie it's true it just is
what it is and let's be honest trying to
jump from one skyscraper to the other is
a bold move doesn't mean it's gonna end
well for you
so saying making a movie that's the
scope of Cloud Atlas is a bold move
doesn't really do anything for me the
movie is like 2 hours 45 minutes to 3
hours long it's a long movie so movies
like that I'm like oh right we'll see
but it actually had me interested I had
to piss through the entire movie I never
got up once to go do it why because I
felt like if I got up I'd missed
something important and I'm proud
right about that you gotta have your
thinking cap on in this movie you got to
go into Cloud Atlas and just know that
you're going to have to pay attention
take a day or so to really think about
the things that happen you know how
things here affected things there how
events spanning centuries actually ended
up coming to a head way in the future I
mean that stuff I consider that cool I
like that stuff is it done in the
smoothest of ways no it's not sometimes
your likes movies a mess it's not always
a mess it's not like it's a three-hour
mess but there are moments where we'll
show like one timeline for about one
minute literally it's 60 seconds it'll
jump to the other one and show that for
about two minutes they don't jump to the
other one and show that for 15 so it's a
little uneven sometimes it makes you
feel like you just snapping your head
back and forth makes you cinematically
dizzy but I felt they did a good job at
keeping the tones uniform like in the
scenes where someone has to escape from
something it'll bounce back to one of
the other stories and one of the other
centuries where someone's escaping from
something alsa I'm in the fights break
out it'll bounce back and forth between
a couple of fights and that's good you
can't have a couple different stories
bouncing back and forth with completely
different tones you can't have the sappy
love story bouncing back and forth with
like war unless it's one of those really
cool war scenes where everything's in
slow-mo and everyone's just like you'll
never get me Joe that can be cool other
than that try to keep the tones together
it is surprisingly good job with that so
that impressed the [ __ ] out of me the
acting is really good in the movie I
mean if for nothing else I don't think
this movie's going to sweep the Oscars
like Tom Hanks was awesome seeing him in
about seven different roles in this
movie they're like yeah I get you you're
you're still a great actor but I will
say not everything in this movie is
relevant there are moments where you're
like that just seemed like you just
wasted my top why they even show that
and then it's like a bad thing it's not
like the moment is bad it's interesting
stuff you don't feel it really feeds
into the other story spanning the
centuries the relevance of some of these
moments is just kind of lost on me the
Cloud Atlas have to be three hours long
I don't really necessarily think so it'd
be in three hours sometimes makes it
feel really indulgent like they were
like oh hey you know what we're gonna do
our epic and it's gonna be awesome and
no one's going to tell us no no one's
going to tell us what to do I think it
could have Illustrated the point of
Cloud Atlas without it being damn near
three hours long and I don't really see
the point of using the same actors to
play different characters across the
centuries at first I was like oh yeah
because they're supposed to be the ring
carnate it's elves right but
not quite sure about that because
there's this birthmark that you see on
someone then one of the other centuries
someone else will have that same
birthmark so you're like okay so that's
the same person so like I get that when
Halle Berry has it in this timeline and
then say the kid from the movie 21 has
it over in this timeline but Halle
Berry's also in that timeline is Halle
Berry the reincarnated soul or the one
with the the birthmark I don't know
sometimes I felt like the movie tried to
be both it's like sometimes they're
reincarnated and they look the same
other times it's the birthmark their
bummer is they cake make up on people
and try to make certain people look like
different ethnicities and it doesn't
always work like uh Hugo Weaving we're
gonna need him to look Asian in the
future that makes sense put the makeup
on he doesn't look Asian he looks like a
white guy wearing makeup to make him
look Asian which just looks weird in the
course of seeing the movie someone I
know got up and left the movie he was
the one I thought would love the movie
the dude I thought who would hate the
movie ended up loving the movie in
another dude was like I really don't
know which means he probably hated it is
it the modern art masterpiece of our
time that people are hoping it is it is
definitely not however when a three-hour
movie can entertain me and I'm invested
in the characters and you see everything
connecting and it's really awesome
even though it is a little sloppy
sometimes but it's not always sloppy I
will say Cloud Atlas is a good time no
alcohol required so who would you like
to have been in a previous life that's a
good question for this one me
TJ you kidding me Thomas Jefferson all
the way why complete badass genius
wordsmith what's not to love whoever
you'd like to be comment below let me
know anyone says Attila the Hun well
played psycho Basterds and as always if
you liked what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
you